foreign
so we do have some new Samsung phones
for early in the year as we usually
expect them this time it's s23 s23 plus
and s23 Ultra spoiler alert I've played
with them for like two hours they are
very similar to last year's phones which
is great those were Rock Solid but that
also means that I can probably make this
like the shortest MKBHD video of the
past year so I'm going to try let's get
through it okay so the lineup is s23 s23
plus and s23 Ultra but there are the
same four colors across the entire
lineup so Phantom black green lavender
and cream all pretty tame looking I
think and as expected the s23 and s23
plus are basically identical other than
their size which means you can either
get the smaller one with the 6.1 inch
1080p OLED and a 3900 milliamp hour
battery or the bigger one with the 6.6
inch 1080p OLED and a 4700 milliamp hour
battery also the bigger one apparently
has slightly faster wired charging 45
Watts Peak versus 25
and a higher base storage there's 128 on
the small one but 256 gigs starting on
the plus that's it so aside from that
you're looking at the same general shape
and design as last year flat display you
know the ports and the speakers at the
bottom the button locations look
basically the same still got wireless
charging still got IP ratings really the
only thing that's updated here from the
s22s are the chip and the cameras so the
new chips are the Snapdragon 8 gen 2.
and if you pay attention to the
presentation Samsung's doing this thing
where they're calling it like Snapdragon
8 Gen 2 for Galaxy as if it's sort of a
customized ship but when I asked Samsung
about this it seems like basically
they're doing a slightly higher Max
clock speed maybe it's just binning for
all we know so I don't expect it to be a
dramatic difference versus other phones
that just have Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 but
you know that's something we'll test
we'll see in the full review but I mean
you know the phones feel fast and
Samsung phones always feel this fast
when they're brand new so I'm not super
worried but the other new thing that I
mentioned is the cameras so these new
camera systems are refreshed across the
board new sensors New Image processing
new AI remastering of photos so it's a
50 megapixel main camera paired with a
12 megapixel Ultra wide and a 3X
telephoto playing with it briefly you
know the images I took I thought
actually looked really good it's
obviously a super brightly lit setup
room so I will say they also look very
hdre and dare I say a bit pixely in this
situation but that tracks with Samsung's
claims of a much better improved dynamic
range I'm just very curious to get these
out into the real world and see how it
Stacks up so definitely get subscribed
to see the review when that comes out
and I can actually test them one thing I
saw that I didn't like though was the
presence of a bit of shutter lag this
isn't exactly new with some Samsung
phones but sometimes you take a photo of
something fast moving and you think you
got it but then it turns out the image
was captured slightly later than when
your finger hit the shutter so something
to keep an eye on just because if I
notice it in this perfect lighting it's
probably going to strike again but but
there is also a new selfie Camera 12
megapixels just a lot of new Imaging
stuff here so that's that's mainly
what's new with this incremental s23
update so s23 starts at 7.99 and s23
plus starts at 9.99 if you're really
trying to pay 200 more dollars for the
bigger phone but there's also the 1199
s23 Ultra again a pretty similar design
to last year but as you may have noticed
there's really two noticeable changes
for those of us who have touched and
held last year's phone one the camera
bumps are all just a little bit bigger
with these new pronounced rings around
them I'll talk about the new cameras in
a second but then two when you're
holding it in the hand they've changed
the shape of the sides to be much more
flat so the whole phone is just much
more boxy and I like it I really like it
Samsung says this was a reshaped curve
at the edges to better optimize for the
S Pen that is still here I assume this
would mean either they're making room
for a slightly bigger battery or maybe
they can compress the dimensions and
make a slightly smaller phone but the
battery size is still the huge 5000
milliamp hours from last year and the
phone is still huge so I mean it feels
like it's mostly for Aesthetics and feel
in the hand and just have something
different from last year but I do I
actually really like it I also did
notice interestingly some of these
phones I was recording with were
flickering more than usual but just on
camera like I'm not aware of any big
differences in the Adaptive refresh
rates these are still ltpo displays that
go from one to 120 hertz and I played
with a few settings when I noticed it
flickering but I couldn't really figure
it out not that it's a big deal it
didn't flicker to my eyes and these are
great looking screens with a new Peak
brightness of
1750 nits across the board which is
excellent but that's just something
different that I noticed to keep my eye
on really though the cameras are the
biggest thing in the ultra refresh as
well again new sensors across the board
headlined by a 200 megapixel main camera
there's also the 12 megapixel Ultra wide
and a pair pair of telephoto cameras 3x
and the 10x there's going to be a bunch
of new camera stuff to test in here from
the improved Optical image stabilization
across the board to the better low light
performance maybe with 16 pixels binning
into one and kicking out a 12 megapixel
photo to the Galaxy camera feature
integration in certain apps like
Instagram and also the 200 megapixel
mode I want to see how good the actual
200 megapixel files really are not that
I print out photos and set them on
canvas or anything but you could if you
wanted to but I think it's clear the
bottom line is the camera system is one
of the biggest differentiators between
the ultra and the rest of the lineup
aside from that it's going to be a
pretty familiar phone to the one that I
gave the best big smartphone award last
year it's still a 6.8 inch edge to edge
1440p OLED display there's still the you
know Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 for Galaxy you
can get up to a terabyte of storage
still the IP rating we already know
there will be no Chargers in any of the
boxes so this video sponsor anchor is
Ace charger is definitely the move here
this 313 charger is way smaller than
Samsung's official one thanks to gallium
nitride AKA Gan technology plus it folds
up but it'll still guarantee the 45
watts of peak charging power that the
ultra supports with super fast charging
2.0 so it fully charges in about an hour
and it does it safely with things like
current regulation over temperature
protection and more or there's there a
312 charger which is a good pair to
match with a 25 watt Peak charging of
the s23 and still smaller and more
efficient than Samsung's so if you're
looking for a powerful charger for s23
s23 Plus or s23 Ultra this Anker Ace
charger is the move and I'm going to
link it below
[Music]